Every Lego kit comes with a booklet
that's used to create the model
on the cover, but it's just a guide.
If you want to create the model
with a different look,
then you'd choose
differently colored pieces.
So this booklet is a template to
create the model with a specific look.
Let's see how templates work in Angular.
Get ready because it's
kind of complicated.
>> Yep, that's it.
Just plain old regular HTML.
There isn't any fancy
templating language or
special way to format the code.
If you can write HTML, then you've
already mastered templating in Angular.
Okay, so Angular templates
are written in HTML, but
how does the dynamic data get there?
How does green get here, or
my unbreakable password,
where does it come from?
Most of the HTML will be the same for
every user.
Only these parts here will be different.
These dynamic parts will be set in
a controller which will fetch the data
from a database.
We'll look at controllers in more
detail shortly, but for now,
let's use this as our controller.
To create dynamic
content in the template,
we need to use Angular expressions.
Expressions in Angular
are just double curly braces
where you can put variables or simple
mathematical operations like addition.
In this case, I've got username
right here in my controller.
So I'll replace Richard K
with user.username.
Make sure that you surround this
with double curly braces so
Angular will realize it's an expression.
Now I'll update these last ones.
And now we have an Angular template that
contains dynamic expressions that get
their data from a controller.